this story is sponsored by marketer hire
in january something strange happened in
north korea the entire nation's internet
kept blacking out the notoriously
restrictive country runs a few dozen
websites from the booking site for its
national airline to a page that serves
as the official portal for kim jong-un's
government the timing of the outages was
peculiar they coincided with a bunch of
north korean missile tests prompting
suspicions that the u.s defense
department might have been behind it
after all a single independent hacker
couldn't have pulled off such an
audacious attack could they well wired
magazine interviewed an american hacker
who does claim to be behind the
blackouts according to the news outlet
they've seen screen recordings to back
up his claims he's known only as p4x due
to concerns for his safety he says he
carried out his attacks for revenge in
january 2021 north korean hackers
attacked him and other security
researchers who used windows pcs in
google chrome google says the north
korean hackers set up twitter accounts
pretending to be cyber security bloggers
and shared links with their victims to a
blog with malware that contained a back
door to try to access the victim's
device remotely without their knowledge
google never said how successful the
hackers were p4x was shocked that north
korea tried to target him though in his
case they didn't succeed nonetheless it
left him deeply unnerved by the attack
and also what he felt was a lack of a
response from the us government so he
slowly cooked up a plan to get even
waiting a year to launch an attack of
his own he says he took north korea
offline while in his pajamas watching
the film aliens and munching on spicy
corn snacks north korea news an
information source that provides news
about the country reported a distributed
denial of service attack on january 14
followed by another on january 26th p4x
says he targeted vulnerabilities in
north korean systems he didn't describe
what those are because he doesn't want
pyongyang to defend against them in the
future he did give an example of a bug
that mishandled certain http headers
that allowed him to flood the servers
overwhelming them and knocking them
offline almost every north korean
website went down so did email and all
internet-based services though it didn't
affect access to sites hosted outside
that country but what did the hack
achieve after all virtually no citizens
in the hermit kingdom can access the
internet only a few thousand have
special permission to go online in a
country of nearly 26 million so as hard
as it is for foreigners to understand
what's happening inside north korea it's
even harder for north koreans to
understand anything about the outside
world p4x admits his own hacking was
symbolic akin to tearing down government
banners or defacing buildings he told
wired he did it to send a message to
north korea that he wouldn't tolerate
their hacking quote if they don't see we
have teeth it's just going to keep
coming north korea's cyber warfare has
caught the west off guard ironically a
country that's closed itself off from
the rest of the world has produced some
of the world's most efficient hackers
seven thousand north koreans are
estimated to be employed in their
country's cyber program they often
operate abroad in countries like china
where there's better access to
information than in their isolated
homeland these three men wanted by the
fbi are suspected of belonging to a unit
of north korean hackers dubbed the
lazarus group a reference to the
biblical figure raised from the dead by
jesus the lazarus group is believed to
be behind some of the costliest cyber
attacks in history like the infamous
sony leak where hackers released five
sony pictures films and a host of
confidential data in 2014. they
threatened more action if sony dared to
release the film the interview a comedy
featuring seth rogen and james franco
about two americans who assassinate kim
jong-un in 2016 the lazarus group nearly
stole a billion dollars from
bangladesh's national bank the only
reason they didn't succeed is because of
a fluke when they tried to transfer the
money to a bank located on jupiter
street the word jupiter triggered alarms
because it's the name of a sanctioned
iranian shipping vessel lazarus group
has crippled the computer systems of
boeing the uk's national health service
and germany's federal railway demanding
payment in bitcoin to unfreeze their
systems north korean hackers seem to
love crypto they stole nearly 400
million in cryptocurrencies in 2021
according to the data platform chain
analysis the united nations believes
much of that money is used to fund north
korea's weapons program including
developing nuclear missiles so how does
a country where most people can't even
access the internet produce elite cyber
criminals the north korean hackers are
cultivated in the same way olympians in
china are trained and go on to dominate
the games they're recruited when they're
young promising students who excel at
math are placed in specialized schools
and trained in advanced coding with
further training at specialized
universities and they show off their
coding prowess at international
competitions the new yorker put it this
way the coding in the analytical skills
on display at such events were like the
force in the star wars movies it could
be used for the light side or for the
dark
as for p4x temporarily shutting down
north korea's internet was simply the
appetizer before the main course he says
he intends to go further by trying to
hack into north korea's systems to steal
information and share it with experts
according to wired he's hoping to
recruit more people to his cause and
apparently launched a site on the dark
web called funk project
can you take a stab at what that might
stand for
fu north korea
thanks to you newsthink has hit 375 000
subscribers on youtube in a year and a
half if you're thinking of growing your
audience no matter what business you're
in my sponsor marketer hire can help you
hire the best marketing talent whether
you'd like help with promoting your
product advice on how to build a bigger
better email list or how to get more
return on your ad spending you'll find
the very best freelancers on market or
hire hiring the right person can be hard
as you don't know whether they're as
good as they say they are well marketer
hire vets the experts for you they only
work with the cream of the crop their
acceptance rate is four percent which by
the way is less than harvard the benefit
of hiring a freelancer over an employee
is that you only pay for the time and
skills you need you can try out marketer
hire today using my custom link in the
description and pin comment
marketerhire.com newsthink and they'll
match you up in 48 hours with a perfect
person to help grow your business thanks
for watching for news think i'm cindy
palm
[Music]